this company's had three seat hosts
they're all right here this is one two
three there they are Bill Gates
introduced a new CEO Microsoft more than
three years ago his name is Satya
Nadella he's become the company's third
CEO in 2014 after working at Microsoft
for 22 years since then he has generated
250 billion dollars with ABI and market
value from Microsoft he discusses his
personal and professional journey of
transforming the company in his new book
it's called hit refresh a quest to
rediscover of Microsoft soul and imagine
a better future for everyone Bill Gates
writes in the foreword we have fallen
behind Google and I have a fly in our
own studio our original search team has
moved on Satya was part of the group
that came in to turn things around
he was humble forward-looking and
pragmatic we welcome microphone CEO
Satya Nadella to the table welcome and
good morning thank you so much and to
change a culture is not easy how do you
do it and what are you looking to create
you know when a company is successful
one of the things that happens is the
concept that got you started in the
first place the capability that you have
and the culture all get into this
beautiful virtuous Locke and things are
going well then lo and behold you need
to come up with a new concept a new idea
for which you need new capability that's
when the culture has to be at its
premium in other words the culture needs
to enable you to come up with new ideas
build new capability so that's why I
think for companies to be successful
over a long period of time you need more
than a good idea and a good strategy you
need a culture that fosters that growth
and the capacity to refresh all the time
that's correct I mean that the fact that
everything that starts off and because
into a hyper growth ultimately does
taper off the real question is what do
you do when that happens how do you hit
refresh is sort of I think the real
challenge for us as individuals as
companies or us as societies and so you
said one of the things that starts with
you and for you it meant empathy which i
think is such a great concept Jeff
Weiner who you all are together I loved
it I think it's a great bromance between
the two of you both talk about empathy
a lot and I think that that's so
important and you cite in your book two
really strong examples of how your life
was changed by empathy and how it
carries with you today yeah I mean first
of all I think empathy is everything if
you think about even in the business
context for us our job is to meet the
unmet unarticulated needs of customers
that's where innovation comes from
there's no way we could innovate without
having the deeper sense of empathy so
what happened to you the FIR which I
write in the book is the interview my
foot interview at Microsoft the last the
very last question the last interviewer
asked me is what would you do if there
was a child who had fallen on the road I
saw I thought about it for a few seconds
I thought there was some algorithm there
and then I said I'll call 911 so the
interviewer just walks up and leaves and
I thought I'd blown the interview
because he then tells me look when a
child is on the ground and crying you
pick them up and hug them yes that is my
first big lesson on empathy and it
changed your life
absolutely I mean I reflected on it
quite a bit I mean and that's the other
point which is it's not some innate
capability I believe that your lives
experiences will teach you if you listen
and at least in my case that's what
rather it is that interview question the
birth of my son and every day at
Microsoft I learn about building Abdi /
insight to be able to see through others
I write that your son has severe
cerebral palsy that's right yeah he was
born here 21 years ago with you in
neutral as fixation which led to
cerebral palsy and his birth in the
initial phase for us at least for me was
more about like why did this happen to
me but it was only through watching my
wife for whom much it came much more
naturally to care for him that I realize
nothing happened to me something
happened to him and what my job was as a
father and that realization perhaps more
than anything else shaped my outlook in
the years to come you know it's
interesting because Microsoft you think
about Microsoft being a leader in
innovation and you write in the book
that in the smartphone era that
Microsoft had failed to lead and barely
managed to participate and then you say
see the sea and CEO is for culture how
does culture change innovation every
to me for a company that is successful
and to be continued to be successful in
something like high-tech for a long time
you're gonna have your hits and misses
if I look back you know 43 years ago
when the company got started - here we
are
competing with a whole set of new
competitors at every given point in time
the question is have you caught enough
waves even if your missed one or two
that's the real question and that's
where the culture I think helps if you
have a culture that allows you to learn
from your mistakes and still grow then
you are then we find right classes I
know it's very you talk about when you
wanted to get to your employees you said
that if the morale was low that the
people felt they had lost their cool
factor you have a Pacific call at 6:02
so you can talk to everybody and you
want them to know what this is what
we're gonna do to me it is not as much
about how we'd lost a cool factor or Rou
any of the myths misses we had it was
more about being in touch with our core
sense of purpose and identity if you
look at it right Microsoft's different
from a lot of other companies in the
Suns
our first product was the basic
interpreter for the Altair that's what
Paul and Bill created and that what it
Telegraph's for me is that we create
technology so that others can create
more technology that's who we are we're
a tool maker and in a world right today
where every walk of life and every
industry is being shaped by digital
technology our original thesis is even
more important and I wanted to be in
touch with it technology is so powerful
but also the success of tech companies
has made them very powerful and there is
much conversation today about putting
them on a very very strict scrutiny are
you worried about that I think that any
company that has done well has a
significant footprint especially
multinational II I think it's super
important for us to think about the
surplus we create around us I think when
I think about Microsoft one of the
things that gives me the greatest pride
whether I'm in New York area or I'm in
any part of the world
is the small businesses that are more
productive the large businesses that
have become more competitive the
public sector that's more efficient the
educational outcomes that are better
because of the work we do unless and
until we measure ourselves with the
outcomes outside of our own balance
sheet I think there's no long-term
success in business so it's incumbent on
you to take a look at what the
consequences are to technological
development absolutely and especially
how broad spread is the success around
you because of your innovation without
that I think the equation is not
balanced well third CEO Bill Gates Steve
Ballmer and now you congratulations
thank you so much bill patty Nadella
thank you so much and hit refresh is on
sale today